we have so much to talk about today so
let's get right into it last night was a
special primary election in ohio's
11th district and it has ended up as a
major major disappointment for the
activists left i'm going to give you
my analysis uh first we will look at the
results and unfortunately i'm reading a
lot of what i think
are i would just call them overly
dramatic
analyses about this race from some on
the left so i'll give you my sense of
what i think happened in a moment let's
first look at the results
again this was the ohio special election
primary
the 11th congressional district
democratic primary
this was an election to replace marsha
fudge
who joined joe biden's cabinet now
the establishment candidate the the
candidate
anointed by the um establishment
democratic party was chantal brown
there were hopes that activist nina
turner
would uh come out ahead and it did not
go that way as of this moment
the results were last updated very early
this morning so nothing nothing's
changed for some time
chantal brown coming out ahead of nina
turner by about
six points just a hair under six points
only about 4 200 votes separating the
two remember this was
a democratic primary in the 11th
congressional district so a relatively
small electorate so
those are the results and um i want to
give you my analysis of what took place
but first i want to talk about some
analyses that i think are just missing
the mark here there
are narratives being pushed about what
happened here in certain circles
that just don't make sense to me i'm not
against these being possible analyses
but when i look at them they don't make
sense one
is this was a racist thing against nina
turner
now if you look you would notice that
chantel brown
nina turner's opponent who won is also
black
so it just being racism which i've seen
a couple of
of hot takes just doesn't make sense to
me so then when you dig deeper
some people will say well what we mean
by that is
chantel brown is not as black as nina
turner in a lot of ways
that's a really weird argument to hear
people on the left making it sounds sort
of colorist to me
and i understand what what they may mean
by that is that
nina turner has more issues of
particular concern to the black
community
as part of her platform than chantal
brown but to say chantal brown is not
really as black as nina turner
that's a very weird thing i can't get
behind that um
so then it gets to well chantel brown
had
significantly more white supporters
that's what we mean
uh whites who didn't vote for nina
because she's black but they voted for
chantal brown
despite chantel brown being black that's
really weird to me and again most of the
district is black this is a primarily
it's like 53 we'll look at the numbers
and it's a 54
black district that's that's a strange
thing to say to me
uh that that doesn't really make sense
so then another one i'm seeing
is that israel picked chantel brown
and israel funded chantel brown because
nina
nina turner is for palestinian rights
um this one's also kind of weird and
you know there aren't that many jews in
that district
it's a mostly black district 54 some of
the
of the white voters are jewish and
some of them are democrats and some of
them voted in the democratic primary
so i think what they're getting at is
that a group called
the democratic majority for israel
supported brown over nina turner and
that's true
now there's the perception rightly or
wrongly
that nina turner is is like against
israel's existence i've not seen
evidence of that and nina turner has
denied that
nina turner also came out against the
bds movement but she's also against
legislation to curb bds nina turner said
she's okay with military aid to israel
but wants it to be conditional she
tweeted and apartheid during the last
flare-up and that's a that's a
controversial term when it comes to the
israeli-palestinian conflict we don't
have to adjudicate it and you
it's it's just it's controversial in in
some circles so
the the truth is that that group did
support
chantal brown that's accurate now to go
further and say this has
israel's hands all over it starts to get
conspiratorial and it borders on an
anti-semitic trope
this particular group which is an
american group supported chantel brown
that's true
um to say israel picked chantal brown
over nina turner
starts to get a little bit anti-semitic
so what do i really think happened i
think that the explanation here is
really boring
i think ohio democrats are mostly
relatively okay
with bidenism for now now you might say
they
wrongly think bidenism is good for them
that that's okay you could you can make
that argument
but as far as they're concerned i think
they're
more or less okay with bidenism right
now and they pick the candidate that's
sort of more in line with bidenism i
really think it's that simple this is a
district
that's mostly black mostly working class
without college degrees
median household income of 42 000 that's
well below the national median
and they're just sort of okay with a
more moderate approach it is ohio after
all
now one other thing there are claims
that uh
brown went negative with lies against
nina turner
but that actually there was some of that
on both sides there was a nina turner ad
in the final days of the race which
claimed that uh chantal brown
is under an ethics investigation which
was asserted without evidence now that
there may be an investigation but there
was mudslinging on both sides so to me
this is not this incredible
crossing the rubicon black swan type of
event
it's really similar to bernie versus
biden i would like the democratic party
to be more progressive than the average
voter actually is
if you looked on reddit and twitter it
seemed like bernie had a lot more
support than he ultimately
did likewise if you looked on reddit and
twitter it looked like
nina turner had a lot more support than
she actually did turner did pretty well
she lost by six in the end right now
this ohio district
is relatively happy with a biden sort of
democrat
and they elected someone along those
lines i think it's that
simple and i'm glad to have my mind
changed if folks disagree
one of our sponsors is magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and tasty like
the cereals i loved as a kid
but without the sugar or the carbs every
serving of magic spoon has
zero grams of sugar only four net carbs
140 calories and
packed with 13 grams of protein perfect
if you're doing keto
perfect if you're doing low carb great
if you're just trying to reduce your
excess sugar intake and because it's
packed with protein
it's great before or after a workout
magic spoon flavors include cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter blueberry
and cinnamon
they're bringing back cookies and cream
they're bringing back
maple waffle you can build your own
variety box and try them all
magic spoon is so confident in the
product if you don't love it as much as
i do they will refund your money no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.com pacman the link is
underneath this video
and you'll get five dollars off when you
use the promo code
pacman at checkout